We all have a creative genius inside of us.
Just like Howard Gardner's multiple intelligence
theory, creativity is also measured in many
unique ways.
This means that the creative process works
differently for everyone.
Are you wondering what yours looks like?
Here are the five types of creative thinkers;
one: The lateral thinker.
This is probably the most common type people
think of when they first hear the word "Creativity".
Lateral thinkers think outside the box generating
new ideas instead of working with what's already
familiar.
Lateral thinking is great for problem-solving,
innovations and inventions.
People who identify with this type are usually
not afraid to leave traditions behind in order
to play with new patterns.
Two: The inspirational thinker.
Do random ideas ever just come to you suddenly?
This is called inspirational thinking.
Inspirational thinking is usually spontaneous,
quick and comes out of nowhere.
Researchers call these breakthroughs higher
creativity.
Often, people who come up with inspiring ideas
see them in dreams first but may also experience
this while being awake.
Throughout this creative process, the individual
undergoes a life-changing revelation that
amplifies their skills and talents to a whole
'nother level.
Three: The divergent thinker.
American psychologist JP Guilford coined the
terms Divergent Thinking and Convergent Thinking.
Guilford proposed that these two types of
thinking are the opposite of one another.
Whereas convergent thinking entails concentrating
on only one idea or a single solution, divergent
thinking involves a more flexible approach
where many solutions and options are explored.
People who identify as divergent thinkers
tend to brainstorm often and enjoy taking
risks in order to explore other alternatives.
Four: The systemic thinker.
Do you have a knack for connecting the dots?
People who identify as systemic thinkers are
good at understanding how things are related
to one another when they look at systems.
Systemic thinking is often used in corporate
settings when a hierarchy is created.
This type of thinker is often considered a
managerial genius because they're great at
organizing and setting rules and regulations
for operations to run smoothly.
Five: The esthetical thinker.
Esthetical thinking involves producing or
creating things that are pleasing to our senses.
The individual may have strong visual and
spatial skills choosing to delve into careers
such as architecture, painting and drawing.
Esthetical thinkers also thrive in the music
industry where they are skilled at creating
rhythms, tempos and melodies that all blend
harmoniously together.
Writers, scientists and mathematicians all
belong under this creative branch as well.
When they have a talent for creating unique
plot lines, formulas and equations.
At Psych2Go we have many aesthetical thinkers
like our animators, script writers and narrators
who work hard every day to create the best
content just for you.
Which type of creative thinker are you?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Also don't forget to subscribe for more helpful
tips and share this video with others.
With your help we can reach more people and
provide our support.
Thanks for watching.